resorts released its third quarter
earnings and outlook for the remainder
of the year ceo matt mannock says the
company is not going to sacrifice its
brand or culture to make an extra few
dollars
while they have significantly less staff
some 7 400 fewer staff globally now than
pre-covet they are still operating at a
five-star level around the globe
now their goal here in las vegas for the
interim to make sure they continue to
break even or make a little money
some of the encouraging things they're
seeing is a greater share of the casino
segment
new domestic customers that were
previously lifers at competing hotel
casinos
are now spending their money at the win
they believe their safety protocols and
all their restaurants being open
have helped them take the market share
on the casino side
i believe we are gaining share on that
front
in october in las vegas we actually had
our best month we generated roughly 14
million of ebitda in october
we had a little bit of hold luck in
there maybe two million dollars
but overall it was it was a very good
month
now as everyone on the call knows
las vegas has uh seasonality and we're
coming in to the slow time
so covered cases are picking up in the
us obviously
and november december are quite slow in
las vegas and have been heavily
reliant on group wynn has also increased
its online sports betting acquiring a
company out of the uk
and has begun its u.s rollout by signing
market access deals in nine
states in the u.s caesars also had an
earnings call today will have those
details tonight at six